Chili's government is coming under
extreme pressure as violent street
protests show no sign of abating
president sebastián piñera has promised
of a wage hike and other reforms has
done nothing to appease the
demonstrators who accused the police of
using excessive force the protests
started last month sparked by a hike in
subway fares they've since widened into
a mass movement against inequality
demonstrators clash with police in
Santiago and appeased by the
government's latest concessions
protesters build barricades and police
respond but according to Chilean
prosecutors police tactics do not stop
with tear gas water cannon and arrests
they are investigating more than 800
allegations of abuse by police including
torture rape and beatings chelates
president says his government has
nothing to hide
he's vowed to investigate crimes
committed by police with the same
tenacity as they pursued demonstrators
who destroy property with the same force
and rigor any appearance that has been
committed any lack of respect or
excessive use of force will also be
investigated by the prosecution and the
courts of justice that's what happens in
a democracy with the rule of law what
started as a protest over a rise in
subway fares almost three weeks ago has
grown into a movement against what many
on the streets see as the yawning gap
between rich and poor and the lack of
support for ordinary people highways are
just one of the many services Chileans
pay for directly truck drivers blocked
the Ring roads around the capital they
say tolls for the roads operated by
private companies are too high
if these highway agreements have been in
place since 2006 the companies have
earned back the investment eight times
over and they keep charging us and
people aren't dead some demonstrators
want a new constitution for Chile one
that protects social services and
resources from being privatized for them
increasing the minimum wage is just not
enough
GWS Nicole clearly is covering the story
for us in Santiago she says mistrust of
the government and police remains high
while president sebastián piñera is
trying to appease protesters with
symbolic gestures like the approval of
minimum wage subsidies many see right
through him in recent days he has
embarked on a charm offensive of sorts
giving lots of interviews visiting
victims of police brutality in the
hospital but too many people out in the
streets protesting again today it's too
little too late and most importantly it
comes from a president that they want
gone the protests actually spread out
today they didn't only take place in the
centric Plaza d'Italia Square people
also gathered in Santiago's financial
district and what struck me personally
the most was how far riot police was
driving protestors into residential
areas
there were hordes of people that had
nothing to do with the protests hiding
out info yeas not daring to go out in
the street
fearing the lingering tear gas or being
hit by stray rubber bullets
so there's a deep feeling of insecurity
and a huge mistrust in the police force
and that is something the president will
have to tackle if he wants to keep these
protests from escalating